[Music]
hi my name is dakshirat solanki and i'm
a systems engineer at tata consultancy
service bangalore
i live in udaipur rajasthan
i have always lived in one city and i
wanted to move to a big city and see the
life out there and explore myself i felt
a gap between what college provides me
and the industry experience
so i chose simply learn course for that
to explore my knowledge and gain some
confidence over there
i was confident that the skills i
acquire will be useful for me when i go
through the interview process at other
companies i did a lot of research before
finalizing the course and i found the
simply learn course to be the most
detailed and practically useful the
learning experience was amazing and the
course content and syllabus were very
vast
i could understand all the concepts of
java the group projects and self-study
guides were very helpful the course went
according to the plan and the support
team was very helpful and quick
in the future i want to see myself in a
good position like the technical
architect
i love to play cricket read novels and
watch thriller web series from my entire
journey the one thing that has remained
constant is my strive for growth and
learning